Panda also allows us to operate on your data frame in
a vectorized item by item way. What does it mean to
operate on a data frame in a vectorized way? Well first
let's create a new data frame. Note that first I want
to create a dictionary where the keys are going to be
my column names and the values are series corresponding to their
values and then the indexes for the rows where these values
should appear. In order to make a data frame, I can simply
say df equals data frame of this dictionary
d. Let's see what this data frame looks
like. We can call dataframe.apply and pass in
some arbitrary function. In this case, numpy.mean to perform
that function on every single column in the
data frame. So when we df.apply numpy.mean, what
we get back is the mean of each column in our data frame df. There are also
some operations that simply cannot be vectorized in
this way, that is, take a numpy.mean as their
input, and then return an array or a
value. So we can also call map on particular
columns or apply map on entire data frames.
These methods also accept functions, but functions that take
in a single value and return a single
value. For example, if I were to type df1.map
lambda x, x greater than or equal to 1, what I get back here is whether or not
every single value in the column 1 is greater than or equal to 1. Now say that I
were to call df.applymap lambda x, x greater than
or equal to 1, what this function returns is
whether or not every single value in the data
frame df is greater than or equal to 1.
This is just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to Panda's functionality. If you're interested
to read more about what the library can do,
you should check out the full documentation at the
URL contained in the instructor notes. Now, we
know some of the very basics when it comes
to handling the data, but how do we acquire
the data that we wish to handle and analyze?